Fierce, sassy, va va voom.
Finger-snapping, neck winding,
bootylicious realness.
Jam-packed with attitude.
Strong, independent black woman.
That's me right?
Am I doing it right?
I'm asking because I often feel
like I must be doing it wrong.
I must be because it
seems so easy for those
stoical, wise-cracking black women
I see on the TV screen.
This is what's expected of me.
What happens if you
don't fit the mould?
What happens if you're made to feel
that by just being yourself,
you're doing it wrong?
What effect can this have
on your mental wellbeing?
Depression was something that
happened to other people -
not me.
Ain't nobody got time for that. Too
busy being strong and independent -
working twice as hard
as everyone else
and trying to make good use
of the opportunities
that now presented
themselves to me
because of the grit and determination
of the strong black women
who had paved the way before me.
So I was shocked when depression
came for me in 2008.
What was most shocking
was the realisation that
it had been there for a very long
time waiting in the shadows.
I felt like I'd failed
until I did some research
and discovered that
this is more common
than I've been led to believe.
Stats from Gov.uk show that four
times as many black people
were sectioned under the mental
health act in 2017 to 18
than white people -
four times as many.
According to the NHS, black British
women are more prone than white women
to experience common mental disorders
such as...
And a recent
University of Cambridge study
revealed that "Black women
aged between 16 and 34..."
Something isn't adding up here.
The data's saying one thing
but social media, memes and the
entertainment industry in general
are still pushing the strong,
independent stereotype.
After I was diagnosed with depression
I suddenly became aware
that I didn't see the world
in the same way
that everyone else did.
That the way that I
constantly criticised myself,
pushed myself to excel
and was cautious about
celebrating achievements
wasn't the norm.
Actually that's not quite right -
it wasn't the norm
for my white friends
but it was normal
for the women in my family.
They struggled to be
what was expected of them
but instead of rejecting the
stereotype, they perpetuated it -
a survival mechanism
which allowed them to
integrate and build communities in a
hostile and unwelcoming environment.
But at what cost?
I would see glimpses of
their pain and anger in private
but they would quickly hide it away.
From an early age I was taught
that you should never
let anyone see your pain
because they would
use it against you.
There was a sense
that life was a battle.
To win you had to work
twice as hard as everyone else
for half as much reward
and keep smiling and laughing
but not too much.
If you were too happy then
someone would take it away from you.
That's a lot, right?
Where does that mindset come from?
And how does a black woman
navigate her way through it all?
Luckily, there are mental health
organisations out there
that are specifically designed to
support the black British community.
I spoke to Jacqui Dyer
and Natalie Creary
from Black Thrive
to discuss their work.
So where do you think
the stereotype of the
strong independent black
woman comes from?
I think it comes all the way back
from slavery to be quite frank.
These are some of the
stories that went round
in order to help to enslave
our black population.
The black woman is expected
to carry the weight of the world
on their shoulder
and to provide the support
and the care for others
when actually black women
also need to be cared for -
they need to be nurtured.
Where else can black British women
receive help and support?
Take some steps and communicate
what is going on inside you
that you actually don't need
to be bearing on your own.
To be a strong black woman is also
to be a vulnerable black woman.
I'd say find somebody who you
can trust, who you can talk with.
It's going to see your GP,
reaching out to your social networks.
We need to be able
to let our guard down
and to say,
"Actually I'm feeling vulnerable."
And, "I need help."
The strong, independent
black woman trope
was a much-needed survival mechanism,
but for second and
third-generation black women
it's a mechanism
that has served its purpose
and has the potential to become
a self-destructive identity
that can actually do
more harm than good.
I'm so grateful for the sacrifices
made by my elders
and the hardships they had to endure.
Their strength will always
lie within me
which means I can allow myself
to be more than just strong.
Out of respect for them,
I'm learning to show
the sides of myself
that they had to keep hidden away.
It's OK not to be OK.
It takes courage to speak honestly
about how you're feeling.
I can be strong
and accept my weaknesses.
Independent and vulnerable.
Move away from the stereotype
and embrace my true self.